hi I'm Iman villani and I play Miss
Marvel hey everybody I'm Matt Linz I
play Bruno Corelli hi I'm Yasmine
Fletcher and I play Nakia hadir and I'm
Rochelle and I play Cam'ron in Miss
Marvel and we are here with buzzfeeds to
take a quiz on which MCU female we are
most like
[Music]
as it was by Harry Styles Brutal by
Olivia Rodriguez Dancing Queen by Abba A
Whole New World from Aladdin Bad Guy by
Billy eilish and Single Ladies by
Beyonce Single Ladies is a good one oh
for karaoke though iconic for karaoke is
difficult because there's also a
choreography that goes with it that's a
lot oh the Single Ladies oh I'm doing
single ladies I'm saying as it was Harry
Styles also he's in the MCU he's Canon
true okay it's a whole new world because
I've been singing that since I was like
two okay Lauren you gotta go with
Beyonce I'm gonna go with riddle I level
it for ya Rodrigo which MCU character
would you want to team up with in the
future Spider-Man Gamora the Groot
America Thor uh Okoye or Groot
okay so I work I worked with her uh with
on Walking Dead but I gotta go Groot
Groot I think that team up would be
hilarious like Kamala trying to
communicate with him and then he's just
like I am Groot for me it's either spite
of your thought this is tough why love
them both Phil has a British accent oh
he says love for him I thought he was
Australia
oh but I want to just hit Spider-Man
come on Tom I'm gonna go with koi okay
all right I went Groot which TV
character would you be heartbroken over
if they were dusted by Thanos Steve from
stranger things Fez from Euphoria
Christina from Gray's Anatomy Leslie
from Parks and Rec Ted from Ted lasso
Alexis from shit's creek okay this is
hard Ted from he's so happy I think you
got to go Ted are you kidding if he was
dusted devastating so yeah he is the
happiest man I think Ted as well but are
we all gonna go Ted I love Leslie and I
love Ted lasso
I got love for Fez he's kind of putting
himself in a lot of dangerous positions
now so I'm like yes okay I'm going Ted
I'm gonna go oh no yeah okay wait no
yeah I'm gonna go to Blossom choose a
movie directed by a woman to watch
tonight book smart
eternals lady bird Twilight Hustlers
portrait of a lady on fire I'm gonna go
with that one okay lady bird Lady Bird
Lady Bird what'd you do porch over lady
on fire okay pick a Marvel actor you
would love to start a TV show or movie
with oh my God I already have my answer
um I feel like I know what his is and
it's not mine Oscar Isaac Tom Holland
Zendaya Elizabeth Olsen Robert Downey Jr
Florence Pugh yeah that's a tough one
guess what you think what mine is yeah
yeah
hey Florence if you're watching this I
think you're really good and I'd like to
meet you Robert Downey Jr iron man is my
favorite movie Robert Dunne is my
favorite person I said I would love to
work with him but I think that would be
the most difficult job I would ever have
to do he's he's not a real person to me
I keep putting celebrities on pedestals
and I've gotten better at not doing that
but he's just like
reached God level I know blasphemy but
like still I said Oscar eyes Okay um can
I guess I feel like you're going already
J yeah it would be all yeah and finally
we're super powers would you love to
have X-ray vision teleportation
superhuman strength invisibility flight
and shape-shifting
oh yours isn't on here it's not on here
because I'm like cool and unique
invisibility I think I want to like walk
into rooms I'm not supposed to be in
like me and Rich always have said
teleportation yeah so she was always
like mind reading but my my thing was if
you could mind not you're going to be
depressed and I think that he just has
no willpower and it's like so imagine
you have it though and you and you
literally like oh I can literally but
then you say you want to move things
with your mind yeah telekinesis is also
that but you
I'm going teleportation
go teleportation with you guys this time
Bishop your personality matches K you're
positive funny and honest like Kate yes
you are you're unapologetically yourself
you're hard working oh my God that drive
has allowed you to achieve a lot already
okay you're very passionate about
everything you love most in this world
you're someone who makes friends easily
and wants to take care of as many people
as possible it's pretty accurate
actually and we got Kamala come on come
on I got Kamala Khan
that's funny is this planned your
personality matches Kamala you are
energetic nerdy and smart like Kamala
you're someone who marches to the beat
of your own drum you're incredibly
passionate about the things you love
whether that's your favorite TV show or
superhero and you're not afraid to be
your hyper nerdy self
we love kamalakon
yeah I mean it's a pretty good quiz it's
fun I'm good also
of questions are
yeah so cool thank you so much everybody
for watching I think you know we had a
good time we got some cool characters
thank you so much BuzzFeed and make sure
to watch Miss Marvel streaming on Disney
Plus
[Music]